good morning my name is Patrick tongue
and I'm a faculty member ad cube in the
u.s. Graduate Medical School Singapore
the National Cancer Center Singapore I'm
also affiliated with the genome extent
of Singapore in the cancer Science
Institute of Singapore I like to share
with you today a short presentation on
some of the work that we and my
colleagues have been doing on applying
genomic technologies to understand the
molecular basis of a variety of cancers
and getting to the Asia so one of the
most fascinating aspects of cancer and
that we now know from studies all over
the world is it cancers in different
parts of the world have different
frequencies and this is illustrated in
the next life I'll cook has been working
on gastric cancer or stomach cancer for
the past 10 years so what you see on the
chart here is a frequency graph or an
incident talk of the top five cancers in
both males on the left and females under
life and you can parts of the world and
what I've done is to highlight in these
different localities in red the word
stomach so in for example if you look on
the right hand side of the slide right
hand you'll see that in Korea and in
Japan stomach cancer is a number one
cancer incidence in these glue countries
in both males and females yet if you go
to the left hand side and look at the
USA you'll find that you don't see some
attacks against so we could and so this
gives you a sense that they're they're
actually tremendously different
frequencies between
different parts of the world in pencil
and we have understand this what another
note another way to look at this chart
is not so much to look at cancer
incidence of cancer mortality and that's
shown here and so these are the top the
most deadly cancers in the world
referring two bread pans across the most
numbers of cancer deaths right at the
top of the chart is lung cancer posting
youtube / battle inducing cousin genesis
but second most likely stomach acid so
despite the fact that these cancers are
region-specific or more prevalent
emission they're actually a significant
cause of global cancer mortality so
that's due to some cancer arranged
between seven hundred thousand three
hundred thousand in the world so what
might be some reasons for these very
striking differences in cancer incidents
and so I think there are combination of
practice certainly differences in
population host genetics may be one
factor but early my colleagues feel that
a more substantial reason for these
differences is that any cosmogenic
exposures in this gift museums are
different and as illustrated on its life
so it turns out that in Asia there are a
number of different highly little
cancers that are caused by group one
carcinogens now this a group one
carcinogens refers to the select group
of eaton street biological chemical that
have a causative link towards causal
elsa and this i'll just give you of the
examples here so i thought i told you
about stomach cancer gastric cancer
and we know that the vast majority of
the other cancers are caused by exposure
to a bacteria called unico vector
finally a particularly in Asia the
stream of helicobacter pylori that
associate Indonesian comes with a
particularly virulent form of a
particular gene called ke ne and that's
thought to induce inflammation in the
stomach resulting in setting up we
processes forget with cancer development
I guess the cancer is not the audion
cancer that has a causative link to
immediate danger we know that there are
certain types of head and neck cancers
cognate offering your customers are
certain types of the metabolic enhancers
lymphomas that are very strongly
associated to a viral agent called in
this case texting Barr virus and so then
these and I'll be telling you about one
of these testing about RS in his chances
later in the cult movie convey with
between a bacterium or virus we also
have cancers that are caused by
eukaryotic pathogens or this in one
example there are certain passenger
where cancers of the bile duct
ordinarily a very rare cancer across the
world instead of Cartesian these cancers
are highly endemic and it's caused by
exposure with it environmental liver
fluke has a very fascinating life cycle
that are also what we share with you
today they finally be awed me this is a
test bacterium there is a virus there is
a pathogen and liver group there are
also certain parts of get into the
pattern of these are also certain types
of urinary tract cancers that are caused
by exposure to class
and this is son recently published data
but also lunch and meet day so I hope
that if you 12 I'm telling you about
four different stories the general
opinion is that all of these cancers
have known in theology links and that's
not something that you can see more and
convincingly to be about some pencils
that are has a greater concern to the
west like breast cancer and colon cancer
but a hope if we understand these these
answers and understand how these
different meetings that impact the
genome of these dancers we may one day
begin to grow enough and startling this
to understand girl because the most
subtle reasons why breast cancers
consequences correct answers are highly
getting me the list and that's the hope
we're still very far away from there but
we are making some stripes and up
telling your culture and install easy
huh so the first cancer that I will be a
telling you about this gastric cancer
and a number of years ago we wanted to
understand the information landscape of
our gastric cubas and so what he did was
a very straightforward exome sequencing
study where we took 15 head samples of
her getting gastric cancer patient so we
need to treat the tumor the surgical
team a sample from the met gastronomic
tissue and using agilent sure select cut
just a cuddle too Illumina sequencing we
sequence the coding regions of 18,000
teams and you can see the statistics
here 7 6 p's their tendency was saying i
put the average coverage of 104
we then called somatic variants are
using standard by automatic pipelines
and collectively in this initial
discovery series of 15 gastric cancers
we identify about 600 fields that
contain at least one non silent somatic
publication by not silent I mean it
means are synonymous of using evasion or
a stop codon and some of these genes
could to be particularly interesting
from a biological point of view and
these were then taken for Lee sequencing
in a prevalence series of a hundred
years additional testing cancers and
this was actually done at a time using
good old-fashioned cycle sequencing so
what did we find from this very early
discovery series another one of the
first studies so and I'm sure that there
are other studies that are coming up or
a much larger scale reading this year
but you could find some sort of the
interesting so the first thing that you
can do is to look at the nucleation
spectra or the mutational signatures
don't see associated with the somatic
mutations in get the cancer and you can
just look at this chart over here or
what this chart displays are the
different imitation categories the
secret context of the different
mutations or all of those mutations in
those six hundred genes and if you look
closely at the top row what we find is
that the vast majority of mutations in
gastric cancer correspond to the
conversion of the seed routine in the
context of a CD value
and this is really suck and this smacks
of the new type of a Valente any
regulation include causing these
communications because methylated
cytosines are inherently less stable and
subject to mediation and if I know how
previous studies from other
investigators is one of the defects of
unilateral pylori infection on the
nationality medium is to induce very
rapid and widespread changes in the
information so this is a surprising
result but it is content to see that the
major mutation category that metric
measure corresponds to lucrative
everything I associate would increase
the able revelation or every average
unit information however one thing that
I want to draw your attention to is that
in addition to the trouble which is the
most predominant category there are also
other categories of inflation is love so
for instance if you can hold on to the
bottom row you see the nurse that we are
suddenly knock a game significant
numbers of mutations corresponding from
seeing University and so if you think if
you go from the top to the bottom but
you can think of is that business and he
forms if you need to know profile or
fingerprint associate very professional
and this concept of mutational profile
to become relevant in a mixed in the
last two values of this particular
presentation another thing that you can
do when you have these 600 needs or that
are mutated is that we can begin to
group halfway analysis on these teams
and this is taking up a commute I during
work of Kinsler numbers meaning
colleagues where they showed that while
individual cancers have genes that are
really
normal occurrence basis if you met these
particular affinity to part ways you
begin to see in commonalities and what
we can do now to take stake in the same
idea we can take those six hundred genes
and we came here and we can Network the
pathways and when we do that right as
you see on the right the top two
pathways that show up assuming becoming
disrupted that in cancer cell adhesion
and chromatin modification and this is
particularly intriguing from the number
of standpoint firstly we going to see
these other grosera Tunisian people seen
this coming up so much in other cancer
types when you use this interim coach
and another fascinating future is that
gastric cancer is a cancer where
mutations in each appearance of major
selling each molecule course familiar
gastric cancer so this is also telling
us that for reasons that I've yet unload
the destruction of cell division is
probably a major driver partly in
ettrick cancer now for the second
pathway chromatin modification that was
also quite interesting to us because we
knew that there was an emerging body of
evidence that disruption of chromatin
modifying of proteins were coming up to
be reverted recurrently mutated number
of your cancers and so we took one of
these genes the solicitor chromatin
modification and we submitted it to
fiber carbon discrete entities that
mimics line so the gene that we
identified but I was and also I I kept
identified in a similar story from Hong
Kong earlier here was a genie corporate
1a and this is a slice sniff we need a
chromatid we
and if you can look at the cartoon in
the middle of this is the protein
structure of hard-won me then on top
when you see the triangles are the
munitions in our 20 that we detected
combining data from both the discovery
screen of evening at the trances and the
subsequent prevalent screen of a hundred
metric pencils and a couple of points we
merged from this is a significant issue
first verifications that occur are what
we all are strongly predicted to be
strongly in activating your either cream
chips or the in you stop codon secondly
the nutation are scattered throughout
the length of the protein and this is
also reminiscent of a pattern associated
with inactivation implying that this
gene immediate novel tumor suppressor
you get the cancer the third point is
effective supporting the fact that it is
a human suppressor we actually identify
several pieces where both the wheels of
our one needing is a human were
inoculated and separate mutation events
just supporting but some truly
hypothesis and if you look at the unit
is no chemistry chart anchor bottom what
we were able to show is that on the left
hand side if you take a gastric cancer
that is well type of art 18 the cancer
cells express abundant artwork in
protein human weakness however being on
the right hand side due to the cancer
that is mutated in artwork be you can
see that he use our one expression
completely
not offense against affordable time the
bases and he was a classic in subsequent
analysis that I don't have time to show
you in this slide reveal the art one in
the patient's record cancer are
frequently associated with humors the
hell pictures of microsatellite
instability and also active in
communications a picture easily um one
of the contributions that are routed to
understand the function of unwanted
other was actually generally functional
data associate that we are one in and
this is a very busy slide yet i'll try
to take you and true we were able to if
you just look at panel e and we were
able to identify gastric cancer cell
lines they were either mutely that or
having focal genomic variation in the
nineteen so if you look these are other
metrics next six already pro house and
if you look at me chart on SMU five and
see that an odd one in booking should
highlighted by the red arrow there is a
relation homicide occasionally even
though we canna confirmed by western
blotting on the right hand side that we
are cool arm or if one a the tree are
outwardly well text cell lines that
express out when it cooking is in fact
1is d1s v8 and we have to outrun a new
treatment or the Eagles are right
present new five and 166 and those who
live in a Cell I do not express our
money protein and so we were able to do
a putback or knocked our experiment so
it kind of F you will able to take the
art one in each cell lines will able to
knock down on one knee using short hair
pins this was done for the schools and
independent not-for-profit lactic acid
armies and if all three pieces when we
can head we saw it
in the proliferation way however if you
do the same experiment in SN u 5 with
just a pair or any other one we put in
the first case we do not see me fight
against it suggesting that we increase
of the liberalism it's not usually a
side effect in panel G at the bottom we
were also able to take the art one a new
take on the ether cell lines put back
part 1 it would express our money and
here you see the reciprocal in fact
where we see a decrease in growth under
community and on the kind of age were
we're able to confer here with
modulation or various genes associated
with cell cycle conclusion so what a
pick'em collectively all of this data
suggests that our art 1 e is a novel
tumor suppressor gene at the cancer and
one of the functions of our 1a is to
modulate self alliteration if you lose
it separately creating rules this
probably but the only health of our hard
working and I'm sure that there will be
other fascinating my future associated
with this cotton emerging from
subsequent no studies so the result from
this first study that was published in
last year and if people are interested
we were able to extend this or in a
combination earlier this year of where
we can take the first for genome
sequence analysis of graphic Tantra
absolute we we know or that d 53 is by
far the most frequently you think
Atlanta matatini we know that when you
properly analysis that South Asian a
chromatin remodelling a drive
accomplishing that the cancer and a sony
data part one day a week in the same
paper we will be working so similar
evidence for energy for with support
okay
you are developed self and future family
look at the cancer tumor suppressive
years so that in effect was a very
standard XO sequencing study or he think
that if any cancer where we are
identified a new recurring lee deity in
about ten percent of death defenses from
it cancer biologists point of view this
is quite nice because you can give an
hour mutti to work on understand this
function mighty development however
speaking as MD ph.d this study in a
certain ways also unsatisfying to toss
in jeans I r1p and fat or which up the
missile crisis which are whose
expression or function is mosque in
hentai develop learning doesn't really
present very immediate carpet level of
opportunities for therapy and so the
next all you're going to tell you was
somewhat they were did the perhaps is
more clinically relevant at this stage
and I will then move on to a study of
lymphomas and in particular i will be
talking about a class of the foremast
called peripheral t-cell lymphomas with
a focus on the natural killer t-cells
some time and it's very colorful slide
here for my comic artists to be honest
in the coordinate hospital really
highlights that uniform us even though
they all belong to the mathematics
system come in a variety of different
shapes and colors so this massive
opportunity under this one I'm subtype
so what do we know about natural cannot
resell them for us well we know that it
is a vision and zdenek with woman so
what we have in this legal firm are
preparing the journal clinical ecology
is describing the different subtypes of
peripheral resounding
in the first column and get to step out
here and the under subsequent three
columns are the frequencies of those
good for mass in different parts of the
world North America Europe are eaten and
if I can destroy your attention to
natural therapies and a former what you
can see is that in Asia the incidence of
natural cavity sound informer is between
four to five times more and in north
america and europe and much of this is
here to add asking my virus infection so
again it's an asian endemic cancer and
it's also a cancer that we do not know
how to manage especially well that
should dislike here but culture / pie
chart shows you the different incident
rates of different types of peripheral
t-cell lymphomas in asia and i just want
to draw your attention to the red
segment on the character which
corresponds to natural killer bees on a
format you can see that this is actually
the predominant peripheral t-cell
lymphoma indonesia and at the bottom is
an outcome analysis of the different
subtypes and if you guys looking at your
killer T cells all right here and look
at their median overall survival nine
point nine months you can see if you can
see that it's actually much lower
competitor but most of the other type of
piece of enormous so this is a asian
endemic cancer it's a look it has i
mortality and what we wanted to
understand working with colleagues a
singapore hospital can pre find new
partner probe opportunities it was very
quickly time so we did the same thing as
in the gastric cancer study but in this
case getting Jordan
effects of sequencing for four pieces of
relativity servant formats and the
reason why is not a forum was about a
preliminary analysis of these initial
cancers that you review something
particularly if intriguing we found Eve
the awesome fairly new TV and this was
subsequently taken for cognitive
sequencing validation inhibition or
sixty six pieces gene that we identified
as we currently located in over
one-third of natural killer t cell
Commission's wasn't in contact tree and
this study business this finding has
recently be independently replicator in
the publication life and jackie was
Murphy there is our Kylie's this and if
you look at the cartoon ever got so you
can see the structure of that tree
containing a number of JH
domain-containing as it's truly them a
pseudo Chinese people in a kind of
rhythm and the fascinating thing about
this in contrast to the mutations are
one here that was scattered in our
approach the new tations exact tree
occurring thirty percent of the author
of negativity cell lymphoma patients all
coalesced at one of two residents either
add related advice of a coup of I 73 and
this was very excited to us because this
happen we have the infirmities scoreless
inning functionally important problem is
a suggestive that these mutations will
not cause loss of function or rather
cross activation of a other kinase
activity pens in international I Trinity
of oncogenic or natural killer we sell
in form so we wanted to understand this
further and so we conduct good
functional assays
and this is a chart where we took cell
lines of a natural killer himself in the
corner and e on the left-hand side we
can start to see if introduction of a
plasmid containing that new cleavage at
shree variant could render themselves
independent of the need to an il-2 in
the immediate or group so normally even
for in order to get me cells to grow
alert we have to add I'll to even look
into Lacuna Coil comedian whether you
can see from the right hand side if even
a copy us to buy or two if we translate
them selves with that tree you can see a
stimulation of cell group and on the
right hand side that we can match that
stimulating our cell growth with
activation from a pastoral factory and
downstream targets that part so again
this is supporting evidence that these
mutations cause hyperactivation of the
tech tree titles and because it is a
activating mutation we can then go in
and inhibit that pretty small molecule
and so this is a job tree or katanga in
the compound is currently being a crew
for use not in good form about
activating romantic partner like this
and you can see here if you just look at
the comment corner if you your present
Bloods if you in treat themselves with
increasing doses of a compound in infant
giving jack a kind of activity you can
bring down the possible set private
activity if you go down to the top be
the new cells actually stop growing and
on the right hand on top scene that
missiles at winco started
on courses and so whereas if you just
take the other two cell lines in the
complete 13 21 are using the smelly site
but remember that you need those
experiments are done where I 02 is
present in the group in getting a five
six crew a negative control and that's
not with dependent on insects facsimile
parking control so the take home message
from this study using a very similar
acts of protocol was that by analyzing
fault reasons we will be able to
identify a new car capital oncogenic
occasion a drug or fees p missions and
again working at colleges in the world
at a hospital international data center
singapore in hopefully start clinical
trials and use compound in the upcoming
year so this work was published last
year also in council stuff so that is a
very satisfying result from a medical
standpoint because that tree is
comfortable and i want to let shift
gears now and talk about two other
contexts where the findings i think
would resume going to be broken already
interested in how do you manage and how
do you maximize the use of genomic data
meaning that if i know the complete
repertoire you think it Jeanne's on a
copy look at all new creations in the
pen sir are the insights that i can hear
of analyzing this data when michael has
been able to and looking at sibility
alone which were the first two studies
that are widely studies and unique
actually sorry so in this particular
study arlen it introduce to you a
different answer to cancer of the other
alta component to carcinoma and in many
parts of the world are this is
exceedingly rare offensive so in this
chart gives you an idea of this that in
most parts of the world the h and rice
incidence rate of this part of the plan
is 1.5 in Western countries meaning that
a doctor be 100,000 individuals or the
one from right people and acknowledge
the connector house in order however in
North East tile and wood has an
estimated population size of over
quickly living people per incidence rate
in is almost 100 times higher
particularly in males so and this
distributed sense of the staggering
numbers involved here you are talking
about 20,000 nucleuses of
cholangiocarcinoma diagnose and on news
5 at every year of which between eighty
to ninety percent of these cases would
actually die within the first real
diagnosis so and the reason why this
cancer is endemic in northeast island is
because it's caused by exposure to a
demek cousin cosmetic pathogen called
August office were really for people to
deliver the lifecycle of all these can
always go to is actually fascinating it
could mean requires three to four
independent factors to be present
collectively in order for this little
group to have its life cycle so just
look at his chart here from collocation
inner peanut medicine you need it once
the X of Omega excreted compliments tool
we find your way to fresh water where
you can buy fresh water snails once in
the senior they're all the changes the
catcher's you three it changes to a
threesome form again Carlos in different
muscles of the muscle tissues of
freshwater fish with a record I tell
villages and are eaten and as as part of
your cultural habits the dish net under
believers use to this particular fish is
like in this cauliflower which is normal
raw without cooking and so once back in
human force the the chemotaxis to the
bile duct where indulges in the contact
causing inflammation and hence the court
set of rather handsome so we wanted to
understand one of the pathways
associated with Liverpool if you use a
nut cancer and so in a collaboration
with content University of contamination
neither car speeding that part of
violently the exome sequencing in this
case about 50 different pieces of a
little foot powder cancer and here's a
list of the most legally nuclear
entities in cholangiocarcinoma caused by
liver flukes top of the list is
typically tree but we also see in the
mirror very interesting other teams the
highlighted in red here are ingenious is
a g-protein signaling the monkey protein
smelly and light jet tree the nucleation
usually as our after hitting just
depends upon currently we saw a current
location in a narrow and ll tree and
other Gilligan company occupation but
interesting lien between with recurrent
mutations in keeper global to the
previously have illegally associated
with neuronal and axonal guidance and
this was curious to us and it just agree
a few months later no not scale
pancreatic genome sequencing project was
published and also identify each we
negative external highlights including
local to hence in activation of this
pathway media particularly particular
relevance to a variety of the
Carabinieri six a boner what's actually
share with viewers how are we able to
use the complete repertoire of
occupations to understand
go team sites and in order to do this we
have to start with the question and in
the field when we compound the
literature and popular pathologist we
realized that there was a very
interesting question that caught making
the field we need to do well attempts at
Connecticut Roman and I was really what
our cholangiocarcinoma is more similar
to liver cancers refer to as HTC or more
similar to pancreatic cancers refer to
keep askin decks in da CS and there was
actually pro and con evidence for either
of model and so we use the genetic
information public equations we shed
some light on his classes and what we
did again was to use a concept of a new
creation profile which I introduce the
random you about the metric tensor work
and hear what they did was to come out
of the data and we compared the mutation
profile of canario carcinomas CCA's in
cream to the mutation profiles of index
red and there may have control powder
different answers this was a paper
reporting you getting treatment for
Hepatitis C related HTC and wonderful
that you can appreciate her from this
chart is that if you look at a different
it is in categories and are able to
craft and you will see me that CCS
increase in pdx enrich always take a
track together competitor HTC's against
suggesting that the mutational process
causing us CCA up we be very similar or
at least really get to the same types of
processes controlling the onset of
pancreatic as development and the fact
that we also see the communications in
some of these new families like over to
i think is further support in heaven
this can also be seen in this PCA plot
where we plotted every individual human
every sequence in terms of the education
profile and again guinea cch that are
agreeing overlapping excellent read by
producing series are apart again
suggesting that there are differences in
the cosmic concerts which is quite
increasing with all three of these
tenses index ecaz ACC's are all thought
to arise from the result of uncontrolled
an apple of information so the summary
from this heart the seasoning was
actually a potential of an approach that
we can use that another data in all of
its complexity to new cultural insights
there are typical messages for me for
the multiple standpoint is that
Liverpool in news currently carcinomas
our district of variety of the compadres
including genome stability chromatic
remotely and g-protein signaling with
the discovery of activating jean has
mutations in credit carcinoma secures
potential therapies and by using this
multigene occasion profile comparison we
provide evidence that replication of
processes related to see cds maybe we do
the same processes related collect and
hence therapy nice hope index that one
may be discovered we also agree purpose
for treatment of CCA because i clean at
least today as the therapies for
treating our broader cancers are the
same kind of these chemotherapy can use
for cleaning up really fast so those are
the three stories and electric end my
talk today with a final stunt a work
that was just published telling you
about another region of any cancer is
caused by export little class
and as I was the attitude of luck this
is up to these clubs belong to the large
family of different species or under
family aristolochia and there are over a
hundred two hundred and fifty grand plus
species belonging to his family and what
is all relevant to this call is the
variety of plant species have been used
in traditional herbal supplements at the
girl in China and also engineer for the
past two thousand years they've been
used a a is constituents for variety of
different remedies for different
symptoms including with us rheumatism
arthritis much information Frances so on
so it's this is a compound FSB hard on
the tradition or all time yes and
repertoire for many many years but what
we know is that in this particular plant
there is a compound called a risk of
chronic acid otherwise even Oliver Twist
maybe that is produced by the drug and
this compound is a natural initiative it
has the ability to enter cells by giving
any form of irreversible teeny momentum
resulting in those found neutralizing
excise of continuing with reputation
across them on separate occasions and so
where does and the fact that when you in
these traditional unpleasant these
compounds accumulate in the urinary
tract causing urinary tract cancer and
this is Internet's chart of where we see
in urinary tract cancers associated
exposure to a need and you see that the
party in the red so there are a variety
of different
music country-specific I was in China
with a very high incidence of the early
transit or secretly this compound effect
is the estimated occluded on one third
of the population of Taiwan me again
exposed to this article comparing one
point alike we also see outbreaks in
different parts of the world there was
an outbreak in Belgium where a hundred
women are cleaned up with acute
nephrotoxicity in some other Kingdom
liver no effect cancer and this was
because they were exposed to how God is
part of a slimming regimen he was seeing
a weekly loss clinic so this whole ebony
deputy medical point of view is so
fascinating story and what we wanted to
understand what the molecular basis
after this compound and its impact
according to Tino of renewing our
expenses and so in a collaboration with
our chongqing university in taiwan we
perform their whole genome sequencing
effects of sequences in a parallel or
learning track cancer-associated me a
exposure and a lot of fascinating things
popped out immediately the first are
striking finding was that will he looked
at the mutation burden of these cancers
in the natural frequency of new
mutations we found that there was a very
very high level of communication
compared to other external cause
annoyance that I can previously
publishing and in the literature like
melanoma and lung cancer oh and this can
also be seen a girl we understand
complete XO sequencing where we had some
fee for variety of different as is
caused by tightwad consonants aims at
the bottom line here is that you know
mutation burden motley cause multiple
different individual tumors that in
patients in need associated you will
attract Francis on the right hand side
seemed to me
the highest in with caught the picture
so obviously this result needs to be
interpreted harder in terms of a kind of
exposure and your reasons for your half
information or just give you a sense of
the levels of making these answers which
are very similar to the levels that you
see in microsatellite unstable cancers
such as colon cancer it's caused by a
defect in your genetic machinery causing
that's involved in google play um the
other thing that was very interesting
was it again we can look at the new
creation context all these signatures
and what he found was that unlike any
other cancer that we it previously
studied there are radiation context of
implications in engineer appearances our
very different these pendants cause the
conversion on it with the words I need
other pieces if you'll remember is
converting secretly so this is an
utterly unique signature repair you see
before in individual because we had
whole genome data for this you're able
to knock you up to ask the question is
there a specific context surrounding the
utility that predisposes that part of
the genome towards attacked by hearing
me an answer is yes um it you see on the
bottom left hand corner on the x-axis is
the preference for the negative a in
plus 1 position and on the y-axis is a
secret preference for the nuclear minus
one transition and you can see that if
you just look into the minus one
position that there is in the preference
for our T's and C's to proceed
and you can do this for a minus on a
custom position and because the quality
of data for example across multiple
different mission these ends you can
actually do this and a minus two across
the position and a bottom line of this
is that the sequence context a sin key
atg is a bit hot spot for all the
indications and so this essentially
represents a very unique i prosecuted a
shingle creek to detect and we associate
answer this will be very relevant the
last line is called we were we wanted to
understand it was a it by itself
sufficient to induce these a mutational
signatures and this was important
because in the natural environment in in
the in the real world human being would
never kick a by themselves or leaving a
context of a very complex herbal
medicine river so what we were able to
do what to take clarify for a humane
proximal tubule cells we can treat them
for within for over six months most of
the cells die but after prolonged
exposure we saw merchants of clothes
that were eating existent and we'll hit
exome sequencing monkeys clones in the
game leading to the current we are able
to repetitively go to preference for ATT
imitations as we're also making
contracts hence demonstrating the
sufficiency of AE be causing that we
start a great answer there are also a
number of very other interesting of
features associated with dispenser for
instance we saw in and enrichment of
these mutations occurring at a splice
sites suggesting that perhaps the
chromatin difficulties with is more open
and for some reason that is physical
body but actually target splice
junctions provide a forum RNA sequencing
on DC answers you're able to show these
predicting disruptions place i think
each result after
spicy events quick releases with
resulting exon skipping or our internal
reflection and collectively cancers that
are associated with a he also high up up
regulation of gene associated constant
media apt right one can also describe
the presence of many African countries
it is also in a nutshell part of an
epidemic classes on the contact us for
me involve the disruption of RNA
splicing and so one final analysis that
we did was it could we exploit that
signature as a potential screening tool
to detect other cancers not previously
reported in the literature has been
associated media exposure and so we
hypothesize that of invar once a human
being consumes and viacom out that color
has to traffic to certain parts of the
gastrointestinal debugger biliary tract
and before it winds up in the urinary
tract and so could any other
gastrointestinal cancers associated a
exposure and so we considered potential
protective liver cancer so we worked
with a group from the Latino physical
singapore my colleague consumed with
previously published a full genome
analysis of her in keeney liver cancers
from hong kong and see what he did want
to pass the question in the comedic and
liver cancer here to see in cancers that
have any pictures of Olivia signature
and also was the only way we can give
you your pc comparison militant blood
cancer there was a clear outlier between
the mutation profile and this capsule
actually shortly a signature our
subsequent more careful interrogation of
this letter said suggests that up to
maybe ten percent of the liver cancers
may have some level of a exploded as
seen by the very unique with music
selection so the result of this work
over at works are just published two
weeks ago inside translational medicine
just that a 80 pcs exhibit are highly
mutation rate any other cancer caused by
a North type 1 carcinogen including UT
lightly smoking tobacco but any
indications of her at eight degrees and
perfectly carpet and extended sequence
motif the mutations are cut perfectly
it's my sights and by looking for using
the extensions of working to clearly can
secure computer other cancers you are
able to link other cancers the exporter
and has this is the pioneer example of
the use of making signatures to incur
new customers and exposes I will end my
totally fluorescence like all of this
work for performing very close
collaboration with the professor gave in
pm and possess the rosin in Singapore or
we have enjoyed can't economic program
tam suits young what will be author
indeed just attacks of work holding
humorous reporter on the meta data
directly from work on to tip for the CCA
work and our single home was the lead
author on the community that work those
copies revista so already talked some
barely acknowledge funding from the
mathematical research council is easy
for scientific research between eternal
drugs and you can us and it can
societies of Singapore thank you very
much for your time
because any questions from the floor
i'll be very happy to take care I will
hang around for about five minutes or so
happy endings
you